Jennifer uh just a wild Affair in
today's game and uh after the opening it
felt you were pretty much busted and it
showed on your face as well at some
point you weren't even watching the game
it felt like you're fighting you're
fighting but you don't believe in your
position as much yet you managed to get
back into the game how did you do that I
just got a pretty bad position on the
opening I don't really I don't I am prep
this I don't play this so I I just I
don't know why I did this but I guess I
just didn't want to play anything else
so I I was like let's just play the
nimzo don't really know it but um so not
the best position but I was just you
know trying to make it interesting for a
little bit and then I think when she let
me um get my Knights like in the center
and they were able to stay there and you
know there wasn't any breaks and I think
I was doing starting to come back into
the game at that point but for a while
there it did look pretty bad MH